let me uh
completely shift topics on something
that's fascinating it's all the same
topic but great
everything is interesting
uh what do you think about what the hell
is money
and uh the recent
the the recent excitement around
cryptocurrency
that um brings to the forefront
uh the philosophical discussion of the
nature of money
are you bullish on cryptocurrency are
you excited about it what does it make
you think about
how the nature of money is changing no
one knows
what money is probably no one ever knew
go back to medieval times bills of
exchange
were they money maybe it's just a
semantic debate
gold silver what about copper coins what
about metals that were
considered legal tender but not always
circulating yeah what about credit
so being confused about moneyness is the
natural state of affairs for human
beings
and if there's more of that i'd say
that's probably a good thing
now crypto per se i think bitcoin
has taken over a lot of the space held
by gold
that to me seems sustainable i'm not
short bitcoin i don't have some
view that the price has to be different
than the current price but i know it
changes every moment
uh i am deeply uncertain about the less
of crypto
which seems connected to ultimate
visions
of using it for transactions in ways
where i'm not sure
whether it be you know prediction
markets or defy
i'm not sure the retail demand really is
there once it is regulated like
everything else is
i would say i'm 40 60 optimistic
on those forms of crypto that is i think
it's somewhat more likely they failed
and succeed
but i take them very seriously so we're
talking about it becoming one of the
main currencies in the world
that's what we're discussing that i
don't think will happen so
but but the reality is that bitcoin used
to be in the single digits of a dollar
and now has crossed fifty thousand
dollars for a single bitcoin
uh do you think it's possible it reaches
something like a million dollars
i don't think we have a good theory of
the value of bitcoin if people decide
it's worth a million dollars it's worth
a million dollars
but isn't that money like you said isn't
the ultimate state of money confusion or
however beautifully put it it's like
valuing an andy warhol painting so when
warhol started off
probably those things had no value
sketches early sketches of shoes
uh now a good warhol could be worth over
50 million
yeah that's an incredible rate of price
appreciation bitcoin is seeing
a similar trajectory i don't pretend to
know where it will stop
but it's about trying to figure out what
do people think of andy warhol he could
be out of fashion
in a century maybe yes maybe no
uh but you don't think about war halls
as money
they perform some money like functions
you can even use them as collateral
for like deals between gangs
but they're not basically money nor is
bitcoin
and the transactions velocity of bitcoin
i would think is likely to fall if
anything
so you don't think there will be some
kind of phase shift will it become
adopted and become mainstream for the
trend for for the main for one of the
main mechanisms of transactions
bitcoin no now you know ether has some
chance at that i would bet against it
but i wouldn't give you a definitive no
and you would bitcoin is too costly
it may be fine to hold it like gold but
gold is also costly
uh you have smart people trying to make
say ether much more effective
as a currency than bitcoin
and there's certainly a decent chance
they will succeed yeah there's a lot of
innovation i mean with smart contracts
with uh nfts as well there's there's a
lot of interesting
like innovations that are plugging into
the human psyche somehow just like money
does
you know money seems to be this viral
thing
our ideas of money right and if the idea
is strong enough
it seems to be able to take hold like
there's network effects that just take
over
and like i i particularly see that with
i'd love to get your comment on uh
dogecoin
which is basically by a single human
being elon musk has been created you
know
it's like these celebrities can have a
huge ripple effect on the impact of
money is it possible that in the 21st
century
people like elon musk and celebrities i
don't know donald
trump the rock whoever else uh can have
can actually define you know the
currencies that we use
maybe can can dosh going behind the
primary currency of the world
i think of it as like baseball cards so
right now every baseball player has a
baseball card
and the players who are stars their
cards can end up worth a fair amount of
money
yeah and that's stable we've had it for
many decades
uh sort of the player defines the card
they sign a contract with tops or
whatever company
now could you imagine celebrities
baseball players lebron james
having their own currencies instead of
cards absolutely and
you're somewhat seeing that right now as
you mentioned artists with
these unique works on the blockchain but
i'm not sure those are macro
economically important if it's just a
new class of collectibles that people
have fun with
again i say bring it on but whether
there are use cases beyond that
that challenge fiat monies which
actually work
very well yesterday i sent money
to a family in ethiopia that i helped
support
in less than 24 hours they got that
money
digitally yes no not digitally through
my bank
my primitive dinosaur bank bb t
mid-atlantic bank
headquartered in north carolina you know
chartered by the fed regulated by the
fdac in the occ
now you could say well the exchange rate
was not so great
uh i don't see crypto as close to
beating that
once you take into account all of the
last mile problems
fiat currency works really well people
are not sitting around bitching about it
and when you talk to crypto people the
number who have to postulate some out of
the blue hyperinflation
where there's no evidence for that
whatsoever that's to me is a sign
they're not thinking clearly
about how hard they have to work to
out-compete fiat currency
there's a bunch of different
technologies that are really exciting
that don't want to address how difficult
it is to
out-compete the current accepted
alternative so for example autonomous
vehicles a lot of people are really
excited yeah
but it's not trivial to out compete uber
uh on the cost and the effectiveness and
the
user experience and all those concepts
correct sorry uber driven by humans
yes uh and it's not you know that's
taken for granted
i think that look wouldn't it be amazing
how amazing would the world look when
the cars are driving themselves fully
you know it's going to drive the cost
down you can remove the cost of drivers
all those kinds of things
but it's when you actually get down to
it and have to build a business around
it it's actually very difficult to do
and i guess you're saying your senses
similar competition
is facing cryptocurrency like you have
to actually
present a killer app
uh reason to switch from fiat currency
uh to uh to ethereum or
some providing people are gonna regulate
crypto and they're going to do it soon
so something like defy i fully get why
that is
cheaper or for some can be cheaper than
other ways of conducting financial
intermediation
but some of that is regulatory arbitrage
it will not be allowed to go on forever
for better or worse i would rather see
it given greater tolerance and
but the point is banking lobby is strong
the government will only let it run so
far
there'll be capital requirements
reporting requirements imposed
and it will lose a lot of those
advantages
you